nous allons prendre à présent la
direction de l'Ukraine 4 bus avec alors
bord des femmes des enfants et des
personnes âgées ont pu quitter Mario
Paul il s'agit du premier couloir
humanitaire mise en place depuis samedi
la ville bombardée sans relâche depuis
bientôt deux mois et sous contrôle russe
annonce le ministre russe de la Défense
seuls les combattants
Ukrainiens regroupés à l'intérieur du
site industriel d'asostale résiste
encore Vladimir Poutine le président
russe a lui ordonné d'assié lucides sans
donner l'asso pour en parler nous
retrouvons notre correspondant à Kiev
Gulliver crack bonjour Gulliver Vladimir
Poutine annonce que la libération de
Mario Paul est un succès or je le disais
il y a toujours cette poche de
résistance dans cette usine
oui et donc les autorités ukrainiennes
n'admettent pas pour le moment avoir
perdu Mario Paul dans le dernier
communiqué des forces armées
ukrainiennes il n'est pas fait mention
de cette ville il parle de la région de
Donetsk plus largement donc il n'insiste
pas non plus sur le fait de contrôler
encore une partie de la ville mais il
n'admet pas non plus à avoir perdu j'ai
demandé à la porte-parole du ministère
de la Défense tout à l'heure si les
forces ukrainiennes qui est qui sont
encore regroupés dans cette
usine métallurgique d'assostale sont en
train de tirer sur les forces russes
posent une menace quelconque pour les
forces russes et elle m'a répondu que
tout simplement elle ne savait pas il
est clairement difficile d'avoir une
communication continue avec Mario Paul
donc on ne sait pas si ces forces
peuvent encore tirer sur les forces
russes Vladimir Poutine si il a ordonné
de ne pas procéder à une attaque sur
l'usine c'est peut-être parce que il
considère que les Ukrainiens qui sont à
l'intérieur ne posent plus de menaces
vraiment pour les forces
occupants c'est quelque chose qu'on peut
présumer mais en tout cas pour le moment
pas d'annonce officielle de la part de
l'Ukraine d'avoir perdu Mario Paul merci
Gulliver vous étiez en direct de